so this first of all thank you for
coming back from lunch
it's always an achievement I want to say
that this is a special table within the
workshop here at Simon's we have
historical of crypto papers seminar
series and we try to visit historical
papers and see what led to them what
they had in them and housing that
impacted things later and one of the
talks that we chose for this theories
which is being organized by the northern
John Daniel is looking to lattice crypto
and it was a perfect opportunity to
choose Daniel 8 to give this stuff so
I'm happy to be and wait and so just to
introduce them in a little bit he did is
the MAS PhD at MIT and it stars a
professor at UCSD and he's an expert in
many many things most people are narrow
but the man is really very broad logic
crypto protocols and in lattices
specifically he touches everything many
of the basic primitives that we signed
the talks over the the morning sessions
were introduced by him and he has the
results on np-hardness of lattices worst
case the average connections and various
algorithms and lattices he also
introduced the rigorous analysis of idea
lattice based crypto I'm expanding on
the work which it appeared by NTR you
and he also contributed to our knowledge
by writing of books and lecture notes
which is usually a lot of effort and
the contribution to the community he
also recently created a logic to just an
algebra for reasoning about multi-party
computation something very
forward-looking and maybe perhaps a bit
before its time yet I believe the time
will come
he has served that many in many
leadership roles chair of TCC journals
and so on he has won the McAfee Award
for Best own paper and NSF Career Award
a Sloan fellowship a Hellman Fellowship
and I have two things to say that are a
bit less formal first of all he's really
cool really impressive but I have to
tell you that this young Daisy also
wrote a motor bike that I wanted to say
it's sort of a story which I found
amusing which the man himself told me of
how you get into certain areas in in
research sometimes so at MIT maybe it's
a good practice they have this exam
relatively early in your career where
you have to read a paper and do some
original research related to that paper
and Shafi and a great wisdom gave them
ela that I taste paper on lattices and
that is how this whole thing started so
a great adviser with a great student you
really get fantastic things so please
help me welcome in here like hey thank
you tau for the introduction and thank
you Vinod and Daniel for inviting me to
give these historical the talk on
lattices so historical talk on lattices
Wow I mean it's quite something
yeah I think it is quite a bit about how
much this area is accomplished there I
started as you deserve the working on
lattices in the early days of when
lattices started being used to design a
cryptographic functions and I pretty
much worked in that area since then so
so that's great that we got to a point
where yeah we give historical talks
about it this also says a little bit
about my age that not is not as good but
yeah that's that's the price for it I
still ride a motorcycle a different one
but yes so well as you know I'll be
talking about lattices and more
specifically lattice cryptography and
well lattices you already saw them a
number of times during the bootcamp
earlier this morning I just have a
picture there I will not be much very
technical in this talk so it was just to
put a picture there and okay so these a
lot
we have a set of points in space that
are arranged regularly one relevant
feature of lattices
is that these are points in a real space
in Euclidean space
so these lattices are mathematical
objects that mix together some
continuous and discrete properties they
are described by real numbers but it is
a discrete set of points in the
topological sense that these points are
refer a part from each other and we'll
see how these come up in the study of
lattice cryptography now any historical
talk about lattices at least in the
context of computer science necessarily
has to start with a mansion of the lll
algorithm given in the paper of land
strand and strand lavash factoring
polynomials with rational coefficients
so there was the application but the
paper is mostly known for this tool this
approximation algorithm that can be used
to efficiently find solutions
approximate solutions to lattice
problems and the approximation factor
grows exponentially with the dimension
of the lattice but the algorithm
performs pretty well in practice and it
has been very very useful in crypt
analysis now that's not what I will be
talking about what I'll be talking about
is what happened starting in 1996 when I
I came up with a paper generating her
instances of lattice problems that was
really a turning point for lattice
cryptography and it marks the beginning
of the modern use of lattices in the
construction of cryptographic functions
so notice the difference up to this
point lattices were used mostly as a
destructive tool as a tool to break
cryptography to attack both crypto
systems that were directly related to
lattices and also crypto systems that
had nothing to do with lattices there
are attacks to various forms of RSA
which are based on that this reduction
and only starting in 96 we started
seeing a different kind of use of
lattices in the construction of the
cryptographic functions so that's not
entirely true and I will talk a little
bit about that but I will use this as
the starting point so let me start with
a few quotes from this paper of I tie so
this light doesn't have any picture so
just like the paper and which is good
and bad okay so is you know some picture
is worth 1000 words but some words can
be worth the 1,001 pictures and I'll go
back to this point at some later in the
talk so in this paper I think it's a
very nice very good reading so if any of
you didn't read it because you know
there's so much to read that's all
better to read the most recent work yeah
you may want to go and take a look it's
not as scary as it looks so in the paper
beside you know the technical results is
argued about the importance of the
problem now in cryptography cryptography
involves the generation of instances
hard instances of problems in mp
typically together with a solution and
you want to generate instances that are
thought to be difficult now we don't
know based on our knowledge of
complexity theory how to prove that
something is difficult that something
requires a lot of time at least if you
stay within NP so in order to find these
hard problems one typically resource to
one of two possible methods one is to
tap into computational complexity in the
theory of NP hard problems now NP hard
problems simply complete problems are
problems that are as hard as any other
problem in the same class so if any
problem in NP is hard then that problem
is harder so you found it or
alternatively you can pick a famous
question that has been studied for a
long time but by a mathematician say the
typical example is factoring so we
believe that factoring is
hard at least classically and that's
evidence that there is some hardness
there however difficult to solve
in both cases means difficult in the
worst case so that means that there is
no algorithm that solves the problem for
every possible instance there is no
algorithm that can be put there as an
algorithmic solution to the problem and
the impact on cryptographic applications
is that this gives no guidance about how
to create hard instances of the problem
so a possible solution it has long been
realized that a possible solution to
this issue is to find a set of random
instances of the problems and then show
prove that if you can solve these random
instances with some positive probability
then you can solve the hard famous
mathematical problem in the worst case
and this gives you a way to pick the
random instances you can pick them
according to this distribution and you
will know that they are as hard as the
solving the famous question and that's
exactly what I Tice paper did now these
are very important result beyond
lattices so he used lattices as a tool
little trick this resulted in the paper
but may could have used any other
problem and the lattice is simply what
did a job for so there is a question
that comes up a pretty often I saw this
question asked the many many times
during the talks about lattice
cryptography a question that is
typically dismissed by the speaker yes
there is an answer I know the answer but
I will not answer it now because I want
to talk about my work and that question
is not about my work and the question is
I don't we already have something like
better right in cryptography for example
the discrete logarithm problem is a
random self reducible so in the discrete
log problem and more specifically let's
consider this version
you're given a prime number P that
defines a multiplicative group CP star
and also a generator of the entire group
or sometime a prime order subgroup of ZP
star and and the input is an element of
the group G generated by this element
and the question is recover I recover
the exponent of this element now this
problem is random self reducible in the
sense that if you can solve this problem
at random enough with some positive even
a very small probability but some
non-negligible positive probability when
GNH are chosen at random then you can
solve the problem also in the worst case
now in the previous slide I described
how you can have this kind of relation
to find have instances that you promised
don't have to be the same in the case of
discrete log they happen to be the same
problem that you can solve on the
average or resolve in the worst case and
that's why it's called the random self
reducibility the proof is pretty simple
you pretty saw it before or you figured
it out as I was present in the
description of the problem so if you are
given an arbitrary worst case instance
of the problem specified by G and H what
you do is to rise this to group elements
to a random power G to the a and H to
the a and B so you multiply it in you
multiply a and B together notice this
the G prime in H prime are almost
uniformly distributed so they describe
the random instance of the problem even
if you fix G H and then you choose a mg
at random at three prime NH primer
random so if you can solve this problem
with some probability then you will find
a solution to this problem which is the
exponent of G prime of H prime with
respect to the generator G prime which
is I times B and once you do that you
can recover i that is the solution on
your
original to the original problem just
dividing this number by B so what does
this mean so this means that we know how
to pick G and H in the discrete log
problem we know that the right way to
pick G and H to make the problem harder
is to choose them at random
however this proof does not give any
guidance about how to choose that group
G now I'll talk about lattices at length
but before we get to lattices let me
talk a little bit more about this
discrete log problem and because I think
that the contrast with lattices
illustrates the some important points
about lattice cryptography and some of
these points are also quite relevant in
the context of some more recent
developments abuses of lattices so what
is the difference between these two kind
of hardness now in the lattice case the
assumption is that there is no algorithm
that can solve lattice problems
efficiently or equivalently the
complexity of solving lattice problems
grows exponentially or at least the
super polynomially in the dimension of
the lattice and so we don't really have
a single distribution on problems we
have a set of distributions one for
every value of n so you may think that
the situation with discrete log is not
much different you also have a set of
distributions one for every group and
the conjecture is that the complexity of
solving this problem grows super
polynomially in the bit size of the
modulus or the group size now this is
not quite the same as what we have for
lattices and the reason is that for
every end you can think of n as a
security parameter there are
exponentially many Prime's P and so when
you make a conjecture of this form what
you are asserting is that so typically
this prime P is chosen at random you set
the value of n the
security parameter and then you choose
the modules as a random prime for that
length and the assumption is still an
average kiss assumption we are assuming
that when the prime P is chosen at
random then the problem is hard to solve
and if you phrase these in the context
of complexity theory so if you were to
assume that when you pick this prime P
at random then you get a harpy with some
positive probabilities like Epsilon
that's what is called a weak one-way
function now you can make a stronger
assumption and ask that when you choose
P at random then you will get a heart P
with probability that is exponentially
close to 1 and there would be a strong
one-way function when you make an
assumption of this form you are making a
super-strong assumption you're saying
that if you pick P at random then it
will be hard with probability 1 so
that's very very strong it's even it is
it is even stronger that what you
typically assume in the average case is
setting and so the issue is that we do
not know how to relate the complexity of
the discrete log problems in different
groups for different Prime's P so this
random self reducibility does not give
any guidance about the choice of that
group now you could try to fix this
problem for example by just picking a
prime let's say that for every value of
n instead of picking a random prime of
length n you choose the first prime of
length and and we know we know there is
always at least a prime between 2 to the
N and 2 to the n plus 1 and you could
define P and it will be the smallest
let's not worried about how about how to
find it now so that's fine you get
something which is closer to the
situation that we have with lattices by
it's clear that we are getting there
with Santeria is very a dog there is a
part of the definition of this problem
which is kind of arbitrary why take the
first one maybe the first one is easy
and I mean there's no reason to believe
the first one would be easy but it's
clear that it is kind of a treat
so now there is smaller than that so in
the case of lattices if you consider
this sequence of problems in increasing
dimension we also know that you can
reduce lattice problems in dimension and
to lattice problems in a larger
dimension and the way you do it is just
by adding some dummy coordinates and
just putting some big numbers there so
in a technical sense solving lattice
problems in larger dimension is at least
as hard as solving lattice problems in
lower dimension and you can think of
these sequences of distributions in
larger and larger dimension as a single
problem for which you can see the result
sets of grow in size so in a sense yes
we have a single problem which is
assumed to be hard in the worst case and
there is really no randomness or non
uniformity in the assumption and no such
reduction is known for this quick load
so even if we take this a very specific
example is there any way to show that to
reduce the sweet log with n bit prime
modulus to discrete log in a prime
modulus with larger a bit size and one
last issue is that this discrete log
problem I mean the hardness of the
problem seems to depend on the
representation of your numbers and the
group the multiplicative group of
numbers modulo P we know is isomorphic
to the additive group of the numbers
modulo P minus 1 but the discrete log
problem in this group is trivial so the
fact that the problem is hard some of
the Pens on how the problem is
represented now you can always make a
problem easy by choosing some weird
representation that implicitly contains
the solution to the problem so it's not
really a formal argument but here I mean
there's no doubt that it's a natural
representation of the elements of the
group and
yeah I'm not exactly sure about what
does it says about the problem before
lattices I don't know any reasonable
representation of lattice problems that
may makes them easy and also I talked
about discrete log with the model y
prime you can also consider other groups
for example this log modulo the product
of two primes you can take two random
Prime's of the same length and so which
of these two families should you use so
let me ask you a question
I mean Prime and that's what you
typically use this probably the most
sensible choice for many application but
consider the following question assume
that somehow for these two distributions
discrete load model a prime or discrete
log model a prime product say one of
them is polynomial time solvable the
other one is hard which one would you
pick
well ron has good reasons independent
reason sir to prepare one of the two
distributions is that RSA group yes
personal preference aside so the
question is if the discrete log problem
so you consider the discrete log problem
over not a prime or a modulo the product
of two primes
so moderate prime or in an RSA group
okay if so we don't know there is no
mathematical strong mathematical
evidence that one class of groups is
better than the other rather than the
best known attacks so maybe one of them
is easy so let's say that somehow one of
them is easy polynomial time solvable
the other one is hard okay so I tell you
that okay no no random so random a P and
Q for random P and Q which one would you
go so and making this point that the
random self reducibility does not
provide any guidance about the choice of
the group and I'm trying to trick you
into giving the wrong answer
so whatever answer you have in mind give
the other one okay but this may be part
of the trick okay anybody wants to take
their bot easy I think it could be the
case a one of them is hard the one of
them is wrong is so I think that could
be the case and well if you didn't see
it yet the reason is the Chinese
remainder theorem and so you know that
the modulo P Q is isomorphic to the
product zp x if you assume it I think
you are two different primes and so this
essentially tells you that ZP is a
subset of z PQ you can embed the CP
inside Z Q and this gives you pretty
much a reduction from the discrete log
the modulo P to the discrete log modulo
P Q so that's a reduction that says that
if you can solve the problem modulo P Q
then you can also solve it modulo P okay
so technically so if I give you this
instance to be solved what you do is to
pick another random prime of the same
size and then you turn this problem into
the other one a dinner i Adama
coordinate so if one of them is
polynomial time solvable and the other
one is not we know that this one is the
hard one and that the other one is easy
I mean there is no other possibility and
it's not clear how to give a reduction
in the other direction unless you know
the factorization of the modulus if you
know how to factor the modulus then you
can break this crick log into the two
components yes I expected this question
but so if you can take the discrete log
modulo P Q then you can factor P Q if
you can take the discrete log module
prime you can still fight you can factor
K so yeah
so I didn't look into this deeply so you
may be able to find a way to prove the
equivalence between the two problems but
yeah I talked about the same question
yes if you can take the discrete log for
the easy problem and then you can factor
P so yeah factoring a big primes is one
of the big challenges I forgot who said
that by the Tongass quote yeah okay so
let's move on so that's the end of it so
let's move to something else yes I'm not
entirely sure but
remember theorem yeah yeah it seems to
me you can also another example is why
using the RSA numbers product of two
primes
if consider factoring the product of two
primes and factor in the product of
three prongs if one of the two prawns
were polynomial time solvable and the
other one is not then guess which one is
the hard problem three in three Prime's
because if I get the product of two then
you multiply it by one more prime and
then you get reduction of course if you
if both prongs are hard and you look
into the exact complexity of solving the
problems and the complexity of the best
algorithm to attack the problems you're
better off with that to prime a product
or in this case with the prime modulus
but so let's move on
so this yes I'll never get to love this
they are a set but so all the known weak
ages in a sense that they have is no
probability so if you pick a random one
I think that you're still pretty safe
yeah no I discrete log is a good problem
and not arguing that you should not use
the discrete log or a say or a number
theory all I'm saying is that the random
self reducibility does not provide any
guidance about the choice of the group
so that's the only statement that I am
making and that's the really remarkable
property of I ties result using in this
pit road you're all kind of sub : since
Nokia
each other being naughty sponsored one
column like design data but these are
different problems it's not the same
problem so is so there it's not like we
are ready so if you take each one of
them we don't know how to show that a
problem gets harder and harder as you
get a big modulus I know but so this way
you get a power of potentially harder
and harder problems oh yes let's see
let's use the problem a discrete log
modulo the product of n Prime's when n
is the security parameter and all these
Prime's have the same size so that you
can actually give this reduction if for
this Prime now if you do that sure the
province reduce one to the other but I'm
not sure if they really get harder and
harder because I mean you have these
small crimes and so you're not really
achieving anything so is you don't
really this reduction does not address
the question that I posed in the
previous slide
the screen lock is not clear yeah
exactly
okay now I know why people refuse to
answer this question okay
and it's to rather than have to present
in technical work by prefer the humor
slides okay and feel free to ask
questions as I then justified that to go
overtime at the end yes so now it looks
like I'm not talking about lapis but I
am okay so let's consider another
classic problem this corresponds to the
other method to find harder problems and
take an np-hard problem a famous one to
the subset-sum problem
so in subset sum you're given a sequence
of numbers and a target value B and you
want to find a subset of these numbers
that add up to B now you can map this
problem to a lattice problem now subset
some knapsack problems are essentially
the same as lattices and the way you map
it to a lattice is by replacing each
number with a vector and the target also
to a vector in a way that finding a
subset of the numbers that add up to the
to the value B is equivalent to finding
finding a subset of these vectors whose
sum is close to some target value T and
the reduction is pretty simple this the
reduction what you do is that to extend
each of these numbers into a vector with
an extra coordinate and then you extend
also the target vector put in 1 1 1 1
here in this extra coordinates and it is
not hard to see that there is a lattice
point in this lattice within distance
square root of n from the target if and
only if there is a solution to the
subset-sum problem and details are not
important by me the proof is out there
so yeah you can
take a picture or do it as an exercise
now so this gives a reduction from
subset-sum
to lattices but in a sense we also have
a reduction in the other direction these
subjects a more knapsack lattices are in
a sense the typical lattice so it can be
this is a mathematical statement piece
and it can be made precise and solving
problems on lattices or solving subjects
some are very closely related problems
and what about knapsack subsets some
cryptosystem so that's something I was
already there before I tides result
that's something that was first proposed
but at the same time as I say by Merkel
and Hellman in 1978 that proposed
another construction that builds subsets
and instances and then uses the m2 for
public key encryption and with a
conjecture back to the crypto system is
hard to break because the problem such
as some is np-hard and of course if you
try to solve it just as a direct the
general purpose subset some algorithm
you will fail unless the P is equal to
NP and the system got broken
you got broken because the way they were
these guys in the structure and lattices
snap sucks into random one says
something that could be recognized so if
this was broken by I mean ready if you
are watching right now happy birthday
and ligarius and at least code they gave
general lapis attack that can be thought
as a reduction from such at Sam to lock
these problems and what these attacks do
is to expose the structure of this
miracle helm and a crypto system and
they using lll as a sort of Oracle with
to solve that these problems so they
completely broke that a crypto system
now you may think that so people kept
suggesting other methods to avoid the
attack but they all got broken and so
this result came up at a point when
people were finally accepting the idea
that yes using such it's amusing
knapsack or equivalently lattices for
cryptography is just a bad idea because
no matter no matter how hard we try they
get broken so in this sense a test
result was really a turning point for
the whole area of cryptography based on
subsets I mean lattices so let me get
rid to the description of the function
we already saw some form of these
earlier today so I this function is a
very simple function is essentially a
matrix vector multiplication the key to
the function is a random matrix a with
elements a chosen modulo some small
value Q and the input is a short vector
X typically a zero one vector and the
output is just the product a times X n
now what I proved is that for an
appropriate choice of the parameters
specifically when n is bigger than n log
Q which correspond to making the domain
of the function bigger than the ranges
so you get a non injective function and
most likely a surjective one so for this
the parameter setting solving this
inversion problem inverting this
function on the average with some
positive probability is at least as hard
as solving some lattice problems in the
worst case
and you can also see that this problem
essentially is an abstract problem so
your taste a knapsack over the group of
n-dimensional vectors modulo Q so you
can think of it as a reduction between
the worst case complexity of lattice
problems to a random instance of a
lattice or subset sum problem so that's
great is a great technical result there
is something else that I think is was a
very important point in contribution of
the paper beside proving the result
which is to introduce this class of
lattices it's a very natural class of
lattices but not only is natural we can
prove something about it and these still
the class of lattices which is used
today for example the lwe problem
learning with errors that was used over
and over in the morning today that also
can be described as a standard lattice
problem and they bounded distance
decoding problem over the same class of
lattices put forward by aitai and
specifically the lattice corresponding
to the function is given by the kernel
of the function when you multiply 0
vector X by the matrix a is what in code
in theoretical terms is called the
continuing the syndrome of the error
axis o is a specific formulation of the
nearest code word or nearest vector
problem with respect to these lattices
which is a lattice with some kind of
structure is the what is called the
Curie lattice it's something that we may
call Hittite lattice and where the
lattices we're put forward and as a good
class to be used in cryptography so
these are lattices which are periodic
modulo Q and this allows to use
arithmetic modulo Q in any application
of these lattices
so you can see the contrast between the
worst case and average case problem so
in the worst case that the assumption is
that these problems are hard so this is
not directly useful in cryptography
first because it is a worst case
assumption second because these are real
lattices and you know we're dealing with
real numbers is something that requires
balance on this magnitude of the numbers
on the precision of the numbers and so
on and it is something that is not that
convenient both in you know practical
implementation situations but even in
the theory so that using real numbers is
not too popular so I don't quite
remember who said that
so there are only real numbers in a
rattly lattices use the real numbers but
the only real numbers in computer
science are 0 and 1 and so usually we
don't want the real numbers so I ties
random lattices these Curie lattices say
they use integer coordinates and of
bounded precision and this number Q is
also a small is a small modulus it's not
a hard to factor or a number not because
it is prime it doesn't have to be prime
the factorization of Q is largely
irrelevant in the complexity of the
problem and so this is the problem of
inverting I guess function is what this
morning was called the s is a small
integer solution problem and it gives a
way to present and use this problem in a
way that does not even mention lattices
in the general setting of discrete
subgroups of RN and connecting these
lattices to subsets some even more it is
easy and it was already remarked in high
tides paper you can use a different
module su Qi for every row of your
matrix and then combine them using the
Chinese remainder theorem that and they
will give you a subset sum problem a mod
or a single number Q which is the
product of all these numbers yep
choosing cube-like order a 1d like some
number like a thousand or something in
each size so typically didn't appear
before so just like use a discrete log
now you want to use as much smaller
number the security parameter is N and
for all practical purposes inform the
most typical applications there is no
reason to use more than the Machine
sighs you know even 16 bits numbers
seems to be more than enough are you
asking about how big of a queue or how
to choose the queue the smallest prime
because into to them but that's kind of
at home okay so I think Russell might
have an answer already answer any
subscript of instances themselves or
some mod and EQ so you can just pick Q
to be while we're up to and it's
actually equivalent to any other queue
you can reduce it then you can give
reductions which is what I like it's
like leaving for the worst case setting
because you know if you can move to the
integers just by guessing log n bits and
so the carries when you adapt any mo
slogan bits so you can guess the carries
so solving subset sum without modulus at
all and solving the subsystem model is
something of a given size they are
essentially the same problem and so any
modules reduced it to subject some of
the integers in both directions the same
a semi-formal the argument if you want
to give an actual proof you may have to
work a little bit on it but you see why
the modules doesn't really matter
especially is enough to secure the
complexity leveraging the user to say
sub-exponential lwe the same argument
goes there because I
now it becomes the same as the screen
lock no guidance is given in both cases
so a cue only needs to be large enough
so loud enough might depend on the
application sometimes that's it I mean
the reductions here doesn't really care
can be polynomial laying usually so itís
proof had a large polynomial in fact it
was for any polynomial time attack there
is a polynomial running time that is a
polynomial Q for which it is hard and
then they was working improving and
lowering this exponent and there's best
results are that you can prove harness
for Q as small as N or even in some
settings even a square root of n so you
can make it a very small polynomial
square root of n you get very weak
cryptographic applications you get in
trouble with you know like decryption
errors that is for correctness in terms
of security you can you can prove
hardness for Q that is as small as
something between square root of N and
bringing you down to two that's an open
problem that's the learning parity with
now it's the problem so we don't know
how to make it as small as a constant
but they fix the polynomial in n is fine
and the factorization of Q is irrelevant
but in a provable way not just because
we don't know how to attack it so in
this sense we still have a worst case a
problem but anyway so this one is not a
worst case side this one is the average
case side of the problem and for any Q
if you can solve this problem for that Q
then you can solve lattice problems for
any lattices where there is not even
amount to lose okay so you don't have
guidance by your total freedom and to
choose your Q within the appropriate
range so okay so so we see the
difference between these two things and
if the you know shimira ligurius at
least go attacks it could be described
as reductions from knapsack to let these
problems which is something can even be
formalized as a reduction bit
in the bounded distance decoding problem
in knapsack lattices to the unique
shortest vector problem in lattices and
this was used before I ties work this
was used as a method to attack knapsack
cryptosystems and I mean this this paper
of Leo Villisca with this title that I
think it really says it all the rise and
fall of the knapsack cryptosystem where
I consider many variants that had
already been broke and that seemed to be
enough to stop using knapsack for
cryptography but people kept using
lattice knapsack inserted some for
cryptography and had been you know
beaten up with the lll sstick fungal yen
and extern and many others just I mean
Fung and
externa so that they had papers in 87 88
99 2000 to the Samantha's always
breaking using lattice reduction to
break like these types of knapsack a
crypto systems this point you might say
that you know before we get to that so I
tie in 96 he could have titled this
paper there following a rise of the
knapsack cryptosystem okay so you know I
can give a reduction in the other
direction and not only is this kind of
the worst case or heuristic reduction is
a very strong reduction is a worst case
to average case reduction and if you
just put aside the assumption that lll
works and as an SVP exact Oracle which
in the 80s seem to be almost the case
the biggest experiments you could run
where in a range of parameters well LLL
was performing very very well in the 90s
we were starting to get a sense we I
mean I was not really doing much in the
first half of the night is about the
no not even that yeah and I had a
driver's license though so at that point
we knew that yeah maybe yeah LLL is not
really SVP is not the shortest vector
probably not polynomial time solvable in
98 right I also proved that the problem
is np-hard before the np-hardness proof
the contracture that maybe LLL solves
the shortest vector problem in
polynomial time I was a you know a
reasonable conjecture but at that point
you could ruled it out and so if there
is some hardness at all then knapsack is
the problem you want to use for
cryptography because it's the problem
for which you know how to choose random
instances you don't have to guess and
bet on one or another distribution you
turn to ask a question okay okay so he
could have title this paper that
following a rise of the knapsack of
knapsack cryptography and so at this
point you might ask how come these
papers are after I test result and
people are SARS people still suggest in
knapsack cryptosystem so after we know
that still proved still the proposing
bad the crypto systems one site I found
how to do it correctly well it turns out
that some of these words they were
actually attacking I ties function the
first to 97 98 is the same paper one is
the preprint version the other one is
the preceding version is exactly the
same paper slightly different title the
first one is a converse of the iodide
work security proof which essentially
says that oh yes this attack is a
reduction in the other direction of what
it proved and for the conference that I
chose the more aggressive title threat
analysis of the and act of the I tied
work crypto system and you know that's
how crypto is is like gladiators that's
what they 400 people going to creep the
want to want to see they want to see
people going there and then try to kill
each other just for the sake of the show
yeah they
but anyway so the punchline is that so
these are tax reduction you can always
look at them both ways when you give a
reduction that means that there is a
relation between the two problems and
you can think of it as saying oh the
maxim problem is easy because it's not
harder than the other one or you can
think of it as we are showing that this
proof show in the knapsack problem is
hard is in a sense tight you can give
reductions in both directions and that
is a knapsack either the either they
fall at the same time understand and
this was kind of clear at that point and
still at this itis function had some
shortcomings and one is that it required
the M it will be bigger than angular Q
which correspond to choosing a
non-interactive
function a typical is surjective
function which is enough to get one-way
functions you can get commitments you
can get some forms of digital signatures
and few more things but getting public
key encryption for example was a big
challenge
it was not clear how to do it how to out
of iodized function and there were some
proposals like the high tide worker
crypto system in fact there were two
other important papers about at the same
time or shortly after I ties work one is
the crypto system of itaiian Cynthia
here that he it was a theoretical
proposal with the worst case average
case reduction it so it had a
theoretical support but he was starting
from a different lattice problem with a
special version of the shortest vector
program called the unique shortest
vector problem
not only in one direction only one
direction showing the unique service
vector problem is not harder than the
general one and there was a paper much
later like more than a decade later
showing that the unique shortest vector
problem turns out to be equivalent to
the decision version of the shortest
vector problem so estimating the length
of the shortest vector in an arbitrary
lattice is equivalent up to polynomial
factors to find in the shortest vector
in when it is unique but that's
something that was not clear at all back
then anyway so the other paper is the
end through cryptosystem which was in
the other class of problems based on a
mathematical intuition relation to other
mathematical problems the best known
attacks to solve it and it was efficient
it was really amazing was truly truly
efficient the much better than itis
function which requires a key size which
is a quadratic in the security parameter
because you have to give out a matrix
and this one had linear or almost linear
for the bit size storage and computation
time requirements so it was very very
efficient but it didn't have the same
kind of theoretical support as itis
function that reassures us that that's a
good way to pick random instances so
okay so to give a sort of so the state
of lattice cryptography at the turn of
the millennium I think that is also well
described by an event organised that by
was sponsored by and true was the
cryptography in lattice conference and
it was a great success I remember going
there it was a lot of fun I had never
seen so many luckiest people at the same
time at the same conference and
so I really don't know who's who was
there maybe yeah
Jeff you have the list of people
attending the conferences so you can
provide a better least I came up with
this list by just looking at the
organizers and all the authors of papers
presented at the conference which
possibly also includes people that were
not at the conference because maybe of
the authors only 120 to present the
paper so you see it's not that big of a
list and if you are familiar with the
recent lattice literature you'll also
notice that the intersection is not that
big
yeah there are many names you don't find
there and names that you don't see that
often in that is a cryptography anymore
the more than that if you look at the
content of the conference in the papers
so there were about 15 papers in the
conference and of these the six with
algorithm pay I try to classify them
based on the titles the six of them were
like algorithm papers another six or so
were crypt analysis and - I couldn't
quite put them in a clear category and
only one was aware applications but no
applications are not directly related to
cryptography and only one was there is
this so this half paper is being there
was a invited the survey talk by Fung
yen titled the two phases of lattice in
cryptography that was describing how
lattices can be used both to break and
make cryptography which shows that there
were there was a clear a sense that the
lattices can be used in both ways but
still essentially it was only one paper
trying to do lattice cryptography at
that conference and not even a very good
paper yeah I'm kidding
I wrote it - yeah okay so what can we
say so in the early 2000 lapis
cryptography was still a very small
research community these days if you
don't quite have a sense with we get
more than 100 papers on lattice
cryptography every
there are so many if you just search for
papers every year the site either heists
paper or the rag of lwe paper is a sort
of the key to tell whether a paper is
about lattice cryptography or not you
will really be you know amazed by I mean
how can people even read maybe I mean
you don't want to read all of those
papers n even if you want you can not I
mean there's no way to read that many
papers and they're all on that is
cryptography so this very no comparison
the community grew enormous lis and so
it was also still a pretty big gap
between the theoretical community
dealing with computational complexity
where lattices were primarily a way to
connect the average case complexity with
the worst case complexity which is
something very interesting regardless of
the practical applicability and the
applicability was also very limited
because of the fact that we only knew
how to build the one-way functions a
little more and at the same time we had
the more practical community dealing
with and through encryption scheme and
algorithms to break or attack or ever
with the security of crypto systems and
about the same time they were also they
were staking a taxi to the cincher
schemes designed along the lines of n
true that we're at the same time part of
the lattice cryptography work but of the
kind let's use lattices to break
cryptography and I think they were also
somehow so in the fact that yeah this is
important but we don't know how to use
the in practice so we would like to
prove T so we avoid this kind of
devastating attacks so the main open
problems at the time matting were pretty
clear one was to improve the efficiency
of iodized function or maybe even prove
the security of intro and the intro
encryption is still standard is a good
encryption scheme and in fact today we
are the better understanding of how
relates to other provable lattice
cryptography and why the cincher schemes
the burg got broken and while the
encryption turned out to be a good one
so this was efficiency was one of the
big open problems the other one was to
prove a security of the injective
version of sis sis which seemed to be
the key to design more powerful
applications like public encryption and
this something that also relates to
knapsack in the algorithmic attacks to
knapsacks typically you distinguish two
settings the low-density knapsacks and
the high-density knapsacks high-density
knapsack so correspond to hash functions
and low-density knapsacks cannot in
public key encryption and low-density
knapsacks are those for which lattice
attacks were most effective does that
got broken so getting security for
low-density knapsacks or injective
versions of itis function was another
big challenge and something else that I
think was the beyond anybody's dream if
anybody in the room can correct me
please do is that you know at the time a
parent based cryptography was all the
rage
there was a cool area of cryptography
while there were a bunch of small
community of people working in lattices
but that was the where the cool kids
were playing and so the idea that the
lattice cryptography could match or even
surpass repair in base cryptography in
efficiency versatility and popularity
was something that really it could have
been a joke at a time so you wanted to
say something in the back us guys can if
they are still open today no I'm going
to move to that now that's so that's
what I will be talking about in this
last year thirty minutes okay and so as
we get closer and closer to two days is
these a historical talk I will say less
and less but you already saw some of
these things earlier this morning
so yeah I'll try to compress everything
in time a little bit yeah over time yeah
it's less than two thirds but I told you
have been asked questions so I feel
justified that we go over time so let's
start with efficiency one of the two
open problems so the so this problem so
I first blow to this problem came in a
paper mine generalized compact knapsacks
and efficient one wavefunctions
liberal I think is a bit longer than the
title so what the paper did was to
consider a structure of version of
iodized function so the source of
inefficiency in a theis function is that
you have a two-dimensional object a
matrix which has n square
storage requirement so if you build a
matrix that is structured you can think
of it as a matrix divided into blocks so
where every block is a circulant matrix
a matrix where every row is a rotation
of the previous one so you can
implicitly represent this back this
matrix the square matrix with just a
vector so if you do that you get a
matrix with linear or quasi linear
storage requirements and using a hefty
polynomial arithmetic
algorithm so you can even compute to
this function in quasi linear time so
you can get a fast function a function
that matches and true in speed by and
large but not only that the what this
paper showed is that you can still prove
security you can get a sort of scale
down version of itis result so if I
showed that if you can break this random
problem for are before random uniformly
random matrices then you can solve
lattice problems in the worst case so
what I showed here is that if you can
break this random problem for a random
circulant matrix then you can solve the
lattice problems in the worst case over
a class of lattices that has a similar
restriction namely the class of cyclic
lattices lattice is the power closed
under a cyclic rotation of the
coordinates so I mean the assumption is
definitely stronger than I tied so
because we are still worst case we are
considering a worst case assumption or
restricted but still natural a class of
lattices so if we believe that the
lattice problems are hard to solve in
the worst case over cyclic lattices then
we know how to build the random hard
random instances by a log n factor yeah
it's just a logon in fact you can even
be a constant factor if the input is a 0
1 vector then you need the log n blocks
to make the function a surjective if the
input are as small values that are at
most the Q to the epsilon then you get a
1 over epsilon blow-up in size so you
may can make it cost under if you want
okay so there are a few differences one
of them is that while before I showed
you that for general lattices we know
that if you increase the dimension
essentially you're taking a harder
problem because you can add the more
coordinates so that reduction does not
preserve cyclicity so it's not clear how
to reduce problems on cyclic lattices in
dimension n - cyclic lattices in
dimension n plus 1 and what does this
says so this says that the proof tells
us how to choose random problems for CNF
for every N it doesn't tell us how to
choose n how to choose the security
parameter so now in the ice case you can
reduce lattices in dimension n to
lattice in dimension n minus 1 is not
entirely corrected because the
approximation factor also grows in
diamond with a dimension by if you need
that aside that you can embed okay so we
don't know how I mean you know absolute
sense we don't know how to how big
should it be by at least we know that
the bigger the better
so here it could be the case that
solving lattice problems in cyclic
lattices is polynomial time solvable if
the dimension is even and exponentially
harder if the dimension is odd there
would be quite surprising it to me but
it's not something that we can rule out
with the strength of the mathematical
proof so that's what I meant it doesn't
provide the guidance but it's a much
weaker issue still for every N we do
have a hardness plus I think it should
be possible using some kind of padding
argument to get a sequence of prawns
that get harder and harder for example
you could define the problem in
dimension and it to be solve these
problems for cyclic lattices in
dimension 1 2 3 4 5 up to n and if you
consider such a sequence of problems
then it clearly gets harder and harder
and you can reduce it but of course you
also lose all the efficient
the advantages as a little point in
doing that death so so also we we could
only do one way functions yes so
surprising easy for some easier for some
bands because doesn't it have a lot and
you're probably going to get to this in
a minute have a lot to do with the
factors that you know that's the
polynomial X to the N minus one it does
it's going to come up soon it comes up
in the context of finding collisions to
these functions but when it comes to
inversion the factorization somehow
doesn't play a big the big of a role so
in fact you know for itis function at
least we could show that it is a one-way
function it is a collision resistant
hash function and there are a few
related applications like commitments
and so on for this one surprisingly I
could prove one-wayness but I couldn't
prove these other stronger properties
and then I left it as an open problem
this was in 2002 either fine collisions
or prove that it is also collision
resistance but for some technical reason
the proof was breaking up there yes
it could it could
nobody one-wayness proof will works for
every and I mean I mean there is the
worst-case side than the average case
side the sir fine maybe I should take
back what I said but yeah I could anyway
so moving on so I think an important
point that was sort of not quite
understood at a time that so this book
was not really just a scaled-down
version of iti Spencer I think that was
kind of the impression that people had
my prepared got rejected when I
submitted to a German conference was
fine as any to Fox that's fine it's just
a conference then I send it to a journal
and then after more than a year of
reviewing I got back in one liners
saying that oh no we don't know yeah
it's not really enough they actually the
concern of the reviewer was that this
paper is using a new assumption and what
if the assumption gets broken that would
ruin the reputation of the journal and
if you think about the kind of
assumptions that we have been making in
these last few years to get multi linear
maps and full sketch on and so on that I
was playing to supported internals by
sending my best worker there and yeah
anyway I think so I mentioned this not
just to bash on the journals was to say
I think this kind of this was a
representative a general you know
sentiment within the lattice
cryptography community that all these
cyclic things are not really are not
that interesting we already had and true
that we can use it and this one is not
practical anyway you can not use it but
it was the starting point for a very
nice connection between lattice
cryptography and algebraic number theory
so
took four years before somebody else
came up with a result among those lines
and the two papers that they essentially
proved the same result
so I remember when I first saw the first
paper by crease by curtain alone Rosen I
didn't know whether to be happy or you
know mad I mean you see you have a new
result and then you see another paper
with the same result or you got spooked
and they already sent it to a conference
and then we sent our paper right to the
first conference deadline around the
corner and our paper got rejected the
for unclear reasons and but still oh
there are two people mean Vadim Lewbert
has keys didn't really count as a one
more people work in on lattices because
at the time he was my student so I was
not an independent was didn't show
independent interest in this cyclical
attitude still there you know even if
they got the same result I'm not alone
two more people working on this cyclic
lattices that's great it's three and in
fact there are interesting things so
what they let me tell you what
thirty-two paper so did there was to
show that once that was that my one-way
function is not collision resistant you
can break it
you can thank all lesions and then they
suggested to do two different ways to
fix the function and make it collision
resistant and the way you do it shows
why the factorization of the of n is
important and a crease and alone what I
did there was to work module a prime
while our paperwork the module a power
of two and so they were both interesting
solutions and let me just give you
another small test and so ok so so this
one is an instance of my one-way
function okay so each block is a
circulant matrix you see the rows are a
cyclic
rotations and how you compute to this
function you multiply by 0 1 and minus 1
and they take the sum of these columns
and you get the output all the
arithmetic is modulo 10 so you only have
to do single-digit arithmetic and you
want to find a collision so a collision
means that two subsets that have the
same sum or equivalently you can take
one subset and multiplied by one at the
other subsets they multiplied by minus
one and you want to get zero it's the
Sun so the question is that can you find
a collision to this function you have
ten seconds right answer yes prove it so
it's easy to find it so there was a
similar hash function that was presented
at a ramp session of crypto the same era
that at this it was essentially my the
compression function was my one wave
function and they suggested the using it
for for compression and we got a hash
function there and then remember when we
crease right in a small program
agreement knowing what language during
the break between one session and the
other and then submitting one more ramp
session titled talk and present in our
lunchtime attack because we worked it
out and during lunch and we had a
collision so anyway so the way we could
do it so easily is it is why we could do
it is more interesting than the fact
that it could be attacked so procedures
follow first you multiply everything by
one now since these matrices are
circulant when you multiply them by one
now you get a constant vector ax and
once you have that for constant vectors
that then find in a collision is easy
you know 6 plus 3 is equal to 9 and you
found your collision and now this method
to attack the function is directly
related to the factorization of the
polynomial X to the N minus 1 now
working with circulant matrices in
polynomial terms they can be described
as working with polynomials modulo X to
the n minus 1
so that when you get to position and you
go back to position one and this
polynomial factors into a linear factor
and something else and this
one-dimensional problem is correspond to
moving to this projecting on to this
linear factor so that's where the
factorization comes up now let's modify
this a little bit so it's the same
matrix as before but I'm changing the
sign of these entries so these are what
is called or could be called anti
circulant matrices which are matters
where when you rotate your row the entry
that goes around gets negated okay so
this seems just a trick to avoid the
previous attack now can you find an
attack now
it's still easily write a little program
and find it a collision and just by
brute force but coming up with a
structure attack is much harder I mean I
don't know any structure that talked to
this and in fact let's skip it is a
triviality so the version of the
security proof given in my paper with
Vadim showed that this problem with this
tweak is as hard as the worst case
complexity of lattice problems on anti
cyclic anti circulant lattices so there
is a worse case to average-case
connection showing that you cannot find
collisions to this and these related to
the fact that the polynomial X to the n
plus 1 which correspond to negating the
entries goes around is irreducible over
the integers so when N is a power of two
so ok so there's a lot of work that was
done since then getting more and more
algebra into the study of efficient
lattice cryptography but I don't have
time to talk about that I want to say a
few more words about the other problem
the one of getting more applications
rather than just one-way functions and
so for that it is interesting to think
of this s is a function problem in
geometric terms as a lattice problem now
we've seen that multiplying X by is like
computing the syndrome of X and its sons
version of the clauses the vector
problem
so in if these the qre lattice and then
you get a vector X the operation of
computing the function can be
equivalently described as taking your
error vector and reducing it modulo
delicous think of it as lies it cut in
your lattice space into parallelograms
and then put in all of them one on top
of the other so this is the function
computed by aitai reducing the error
modulo the lattice
now at this point you can ask is this
function
hard and for what values of the
parameters now when the size of the
error is less
half at the minimum distance of de la
pista this function is injective
so all these fragments of a ball do not
intersect even when you reduce it model
of the lattice now if you choose a
larger error at some point they start
intersecting the function is not
injective anymore and if you make it big
enough and then the function will become
surjective it will cover the entire
space and you don't need to make it that
much bigger to get something which is
not only subjectivity is also regular so
notice here different regions have
different shades of red or pink I'm not
sure so I often get into you know in
discussions about whether the difference
between red and pink the discussion is
typically about the color of my shirt
you know it is light red it is like the
latter common that I used it was red and
then by use only you know 50% or 70% so
so here when you make it bigger you
still have the different shades but the
difference is much much less and so you
get something that it's almost regular
at every point is roughly the same
number of play images and these function
maps to the uniform distribution and so
you can ask so is this a one-way
function and in what range of parameters
and I ties show that in this case when
the function is surjective and uniform
then the function is hard to invert and
the question and there was a key to
designing public key encryption schemes
based on that it was so can you sure
that this function is injective it's a
hard to invert even in the injective
range of parameters and this is the
question that was answered
perhaps implicitly by Oded ragas in his
paper on lattices learning with errors
non-random linear codes and cryptography
and I said implicitly because this was
proved they're not used in the SAS
problem in fact I'm not even sure it was
clear to him that the problem was the
what he was doing was
to prove the harness of itis function
but for injective values of the
parameters
it was the formulating coming up
proposing a new formulation of the
problem called the learning with errors
and just using a lot is duality it's
easy to show that there are different
formulations of the same problem so and
not only that but so in the way he did
that was even more surprising he could
prove that the function was hard to
invert in the injective setting using
quantum computation so that's why it
seems so out of reach before and still
today we don't quite know how to relate
these two problems using classical tools
so technically use the quantum Fourier
transform and to move from one lattice
to its dual so beside that perhaps less
surprisingly it also showed that if this
function is one way which is shorter
than it is also pseudo random in the
sense that the output of the function is
indistinguishable from a uniformly
random value I said less surprisingly
because if you formulate it in the SAS
version so like a knapsack version there
were already results by Russ Olympiad so
in money now are showing that the subset
sum problem if it is one way then it is
pseudo-random that's something that we
already knew using this formulation
perhaps it was less clear when using the
other one and and finally it could be
used for public encryption so he gave
this application which was great because
at that time with so that it was an
application based on the worst case
assumption of the quantum hardness of
lattice problems but he could get public
key encryption a serious and useful
application that you can potentially
sell and making other money out of it
so ok so the you already saw this in the
morning many times so yeah I'll just
skip it so these so syntactical it
different from the previous as I guess
function because of this addition here
but indeed you can refresh it by taking
the dual of a the orthogonal complement
of a and then use it as a parity check
for E and you get an equivalent function
that is syntactically similar to I ty
but for different parameters now w/e
really had a huge impact in cryptography
staff tur starting with 2008 we started
seeing more and more complex
applications from lawsuit rafter
functions and CCA secure encryption
identity based encryption hierarchical
and so on oblivious transferring all the
way to fully homomorphic encryption and
something that I heard that many times
since then was that oh you know what is
that really the great thing about this
lwe problem and is the paper of record
so he introduced this problem that
allows you to do lattice cryptography
without even knowing what a lattice is
and I mean each time I hear that I
really don't know what tonight I feel
like crying almost ok because sure I
mean he introduced a new problem but I
honestly think that's almost a negative
contribution because that yeah confused
everybody because they couldn't see that
oh yeah that's the injective version of
iodized function no this wasn't in
totally different and but at the same
time I what he did was to prove that
that function was one way something it
was a big oven problem and yeah we
compared it to the introduction of a
difference in tactical formulation and
it's a much bigger much bigger
achievement that was really really
surprising if you look at it from a
lattice perspective anyway I think that
to be fair if there are you know hundred
papers a year on that is cryptography
now I think is also because of the fact
that yes you can do that this
cryptography without
knowing what a lot is is now I think you
can do that equally well using the SIS
formulation it's not something that I
mean this is something that is often
attributed to del w formulation but most
of these applications you can wear them
around and use the X function but for a
range of parameters that were proof
secured only by a Fraggle so that
without that it would be just better to
use those functions yes so depend on
which problem is start from so they've
been classic reductions showing hardness
also for these for this function so the
difference is the site i-ight I proved
that the problem was as hard as salt as
finding and short linearly independent
vectors in a lattice in the worst case
so the classic reductions only show you
that it is as hard as computing the
length of the shortest vector in the
lattice back without finding it so it is
still very interesting and it was a so
this was achieved the first by a crease
peickert and the proving a sort of
classic hardness F for this problem
starting from gap is VP is something you
could think of it as a big one theis
version of Oded proof but it's not
really the quantized meaning that the
part where quantum was used is still
that we don't know how to make that part
classical but still that reinforces our
confidence in the problem but at the
same time so this kind of proof so they
do not carry over to the algebraic
setting so there are open problems
related to it's an area that is not
completely solved and so there is one
more paper that I should mention
very nerve from last went two years ago
that way I'm blanking out but yeah there
are four people in the room that they
know what I'm talking about and please
yeah he want to hear that
yeah please raise your hand and so so
anyway so I'm trying to close
yeah potato to get to the end of the
talk here right so here there was the
opposite of what we had before it's
something that taser is a it is a
inefficient ascites function so it is
practically useful but only
theoretically efficient and so these are
sort of background slide but so this is
AC code
yeah in 75 yeah it's no it is not is a
lattice crypto function so you know so
does this just a hash function so at the
time I get in something that was
practically useful was still a big
challenge and but in the case of hash
functions in 2008 we managed to find a
truly practical implementation of those
functions is something that could really
go as fast as you want it was a hash
function as fast as shadow using various
implementation tricks and that was
probably the first word that showed that
yes you can make this lattice
cryptography using cyclic lattices
really really efficient it's not
surprisingly yeah I wrote a little
program to find the best parameters and
the answer turns out to be 42 so if so
we didn't know to what question that it
was the answer before so this paper
answered the question what is the
question to the 42 answer and anyway so
let's move on so if you try to put these
you know sort of the foundational papers
in a table we have this or objective and
injective versions of these sis function
and we have
the less efficient and more efficient
version depending on whether you use
structural lattices or not and I tie
found that this all area given a
surjective function based on general
lattice rag have got the efficient they
more powerful injective version that has
tons of applications but still
inefficient then the cyclic lattice work
got efficiency but only here so you can
ask okay we should put something there
and that was was done by duplication
skip a curtain rose and an R a gap in
2010 giving basically combining these
two things so technically they to do
much more than that and proving pseudo
randomness of this function was
something that brought even more
algebraic number theory into the game so
there are several other related papers
that technically they are equally
important and one of them is I like to
mention is the paper in 2009 that it
predates this one by a little bit I
think that technically the results are
independent by Damien Stella and others
that showed that this function was one
way but without showing pseudo
randomness the technical is very very
interesting and nice I really like the
proof but proving pseudo randomness in
essence is really there what was needed
to get the fast and powerful
applications and so let me close with a
chi fully homomorphic encryption which i
mentioned in the title but i'm not going
to say a lot about it because you you
know it's I mean it's already history I
mean it's a
Craig result but you heard about it in
the morning and so Craig Gentry in 2009
did something really amazing and I think
that even northern solving the problem
and what he did was to convince people
that the problem could be solved and
similarly to what I did in you know
taking this knapsack problem that
everybody was throwing anyway and say oh
no no this is something that is
completely different you can do it same
thing yes all of a sudden everybody in
cryptography started thinking that oh
yes it can be solved and it also brought
a lot of attention and publicity to
lattice cryptography which is good so
nobody complained about it but now after
some time I think that we can finally
said it all perhaps for the wrong reason
okay so and the wrong reason is that the
way he was using lattices was very
different from ayah he was not using
that class of lattices he was using a
lot of a doc assumptions which we are
it's not as clear how confident we can
be about them and related to that -
there were also some efficiency issues
so there were several papers after that
that got second generation third
generation I don't know it up to what
generation we got at this point of
better ways to do fully homomorphic
encryption based on problems which now
are essentially lwe the same bounded
distance decoding on iodized lattices so
why I said perhaps for the wrong reasons
because so gently used the ring lattices
these algebraic lattices and it's in the
paper
he's it seemed essential to get a fully
homomorphic encryption you want lattices
support but addition and multiplication
in order to get a complete set of
boolean gates and it turned out that
that's not really necessary so that's
useful for efficiency but not quite the
case it was using a different class of
lattices there really a key feature that
was important that is still present in
all these are a new era scheme is that
lattice cryptography has a very fast
decryption algorithm that's
really something that is unique to
Loftus cryptography decryption
essentially is a scholar product you saw
these this morning goes in how texts
talk and if we look at the AG today it's
quite different so the in fact I mean
it's quite different to the first
candidate proposal the increase effigy
encryption today is essentially ragged
LW encryption or or variants of it and
the security is based on standard
assumptions lwe or worst case the
hardness assumptions on lattices there
is no need of ring lattices except for
efficiency and it is also much faster
and we'll understood then the first
candidate so a few concluding remarks so
I tie this connection sure is not as
powerful as lwe we can not do fully
homomorphic encryption just using that
but the impact of that work on that is
repet ography is something again we can
still see today so you can think of this
plus of curie lattices that was brought
to the cryptographers of tensions in
that work and we still use them today we
great as access and the theory behind
the proof really put lattice
cryptographers on the right track to get
both faster functions and better
understanding of what you're doing and
of course I only mention that also going
back to shock I only mention a small
fraction of all the works that I should
I should have that deserved to be
mentioned that there was because of
timing constraints and and there is
clearly still plenty of work to be done
on many fronts from getting better
understanding of this algebraic lab this
is two implementations
implementation of its cryptography is
not about coding is about mathematics so
what makes these things efficiently to
implement is the choice of parameters
that allows you to exploit structured
algorithms like FFT algorithms number
theory transformer and so on
and there is a great potential for
paralyzed ability and hardware
computation because you're working with
vectors and I saw it sooner or later
we'll have you know the newest
generation processors with instructions
that have support lattice cryptography
so that's something that you know back
at 20 years ago at the time of you know
the 1996 that would have been now we
already had that there was only using
addition an addition is well supported
by computers that maybe will go beyond
that and for all these recent work on
obfuscation multilinear maps and so on
basing those functions on standard
lattice problems I think is really the
key to move forward both in terms of
efficiency and also really do something
like real cryptographers alone would say
yeah it's real grabbers don't use of
force question so but so with the you
know confident confidence that we know
what we are doing now when using
lattices and the security estimate yes
so getting concrete values of security
for lattice cryptography also is
something that I think requires a more
attention and the reason is that most of
the algorithmic work that was done
before and after I Thais work was to a
large extent done in the context of
breaking things now when you break
things you are in a different kind of
setting than when you are trying to
estimate parameters if you want to break
a scheme you just try to attack a
challenge you break it fine and the
scheme is that so if you want to get
confidence of how much it would cost you
to break something you need the Sun more
algorithmic and you know statistical
study of the problem and it is not
focused on a single instance but tries
to improve our understanding of the
performance of the algorithms so
revisiting many of the algorithmic
problems on lattices I think it could
help in that direction so that's
concludes my talk or so thank you all
for your attention
no quantum proof yes with the quantum
proof yeah
in fact the quantum proof you can
describe the quantum proof as a
reduction between the search problem to
the decision problem so yes so in one
direction there is a classical proof it
just as a complexity question can we
relate the complexity of search si VP
with a complexity of gap SVP so there is
one trivial radar classical reduction in
one direction in the other direction we
only have the quantum reductions that
for the were in the worst case setting
that's what was done in a dead paper in
the average case setting that was was
done by the nienna in the SS TX paper
where they did something like that going
between average case problems but that's
only one to me by gives hardness based
on a search problem
classically or quantum me quantum is the
same yeah digital signatures no but you
can do it directly you can do efficient
signatures no then yeah I think that's
it pretty much they're all the problems
that can be reduced into one way
function so commitments I mean the kind
of yeah that you can work on work when
pollution resistant is the only one for
which we have no reduction by everything
else is a polynomial time equivalent to
one-way functions yes it is I mean the
best way that we know to estimate the
length of the shortest vector is by
finding it we don't have accepting their
algebraic setting but in the classical
setting I'm not sure if algorithmically
there is anything that can be exploited
that the search version that the
decision version is polynomially
equivalent to the unique shortest vector
problem which is considered easier in
crypt analysis if you apply the
reduction then what you gain that way
you lose it in the reduction so it's not
clear if that's a good way to estimate
the length of the shortest vector yeah
it was a question about yeah
you said you do single degree was no
know what's good because it brought I
think it brought many so many people to
the field for the wrong reason but I
mean still good that's all I'm happy
about it
same thing you know the publicity from
you know that I hate G and so great I
mean natural geometric way to think
about it right
so that in fact my former advisor used
to ask me instead
what is the geometry do you still think
that's that's you know without the chief
for instance you know there is still a
natural geometric way that is
so first also my advisor wrote only the
same thing and yes so some of the things
you were showing me this morning and
then okay this looks like a trick just
matrix manipulation you multiply things
only because the dimension matches and
things work out great and you can check
that it's correct I believe that there
should be some kind of geometric
interpretation and even if you don't
need it to carry out the truth it can be
interesting and there is something to
learn from trying to do that they might
give ideas to do other things more
things or even getting a better
understanding of what we are doing so
yeah I'm a true believer in geometry
Turing the geometric will of lattice
cryptography I think will go outside
here and we will see you all tomorrow
morning and let's thank the me in Vegas